hey henry hey eva good to see you both
really good this is hi
what a great lineup you two of course hi
hi hi
so we know that it stands for latin
moment
so here's the question was there a
moment eva that led to this event
tonight
yeah i mean i think this has been a long
time coming you know
uh momento latino we did a study
that showed frontline worker 34 of
frontline workers
are from the latinx community that's
your nurses
and your drivers and your farm workers
and so
a large part of people from our
community are
keeping the engine of this economy going
during a global pandemic and we thought
how do we
honor these heroes these people that are
often going to work without ppe
without livable wages with horrible
living conditions
and we thought we need to say thank you
and let our community know we are here
for you we
see you and we thank you yeah you're so
right they are
true frontline frontline workers henry i
think i wonder if people understand
the power of the latino community do you
think even they understand the power
that they have
no i think this is the moment when the
latino community needs to understand
that they're the future of this country
but we've been told for so long that we
don't matter it's important for us to go
back and celebrate our imprint on
culture on heritage on history
and our role in the economy of this
country and momento latino begins to do
that i think
yeah eva you know listen we all saw you
at the democratic convention in fact you
kicked it off
and there were some there were some eye
rolls in political circles that say
she's an actress she's a housewife
what does she know about politics i want
to know your reaction to that
oh gosh you know i i've gotten that my
whole life when i was when i was a kid
in college
you're a kid in college you shouldn't
have a voice you know i had a
i worked at wendy's and i was uh cam i
was campaigning when i worked at wendy's
ah
you're just you know a minimum age
worker you don't understand these big
things
so people will always try to discourage
you to be part of democracy the point is
i showed up as an american that night i
showed up as a patriot i showed up as a
ninth generation texan
i showed up as the daughter of a teacher
and the daughter of a veteran
um so you know by that logic of like oh
shut up and act i always say
you know if you're a dentist then okay
go do teeth your teacher
just teach no that's not how it works
that's what i do it's not who i
am i know that's such a good analogy and
henry i think people don't realize
you don't have to be a politician to be
political
you don't have to be rich to be a
philanthropist
every american and in particular the
latino community we are philanthropists
we are patriots we are heroes and
momento latino is meant to
bring those stories forward so that we
can feel better so that we can be
hopeful and inspired
and if there's ever a moment in our
country's history where we need that
inspiration and that
cultural understanding i think it's
right now
i love eva there's a great article in
the washington post i hope you've read
it about yourself it says
if you don't know why eva longoria is a
political power broker you have not been
paying attention
because here you are you're producing
you're directing and i love something i
heard you say recently that you try to
adopt the attitude of a man what do you
mean by that when you walk
in a room yeah and i don't mean that in
like we all have to be men to get
yeah it was just there's there's a sense
of white male privilege obviously that
that the world operates on
and yeah i just i was doing a pitch
pitching myself for a job one time and a
really good friend of mine
said whoa whoa i got to stop your pitch
and i said why and he said i want you to
walk out the door
put your white male privileged pants on
and come back into the room and assume
you have that job
assume it's yours you know and i was
like oh no i would never
do that you know as a as a latina and as
a woman i was like no no i want them to
know i'm collaborative i want them to
know that
i would be okay you know if they had
changes and he's like no
go in with your vision and make sure
that you know he allowed me to assume
i was equal assume you're equal right
and that was like
yeah i am why why wouldn't i assume that
so it was it was eye-opening it was an
aha moment for me i i think it's such
good advice guys and i always say it's
always good to be underestimated and
then over deliver
what do you what are you most excited
about henry i'll let you have the last
word about tonight
well i i think that you're gonna laugh a
little bit you're gonna
dance a little bit but at the end of the
day you're going to be inspired by the
stories of the everyday heroes who have
kept this country moving
lucky the longoria i always say eva
longoria for future president of the
united states
all right we can say you said it here
first henry listen
laughing dancing and inspiration i'm in
thank you both guys
thank you both thank you gail thank you
so much all right thank you gail
see ya bye bye
bye you can watch the hour-long special
essential
essential heroes momento latino event
tonight at 9 8 central right here on cbs